[Music]
following betty white's death on
december 31st 2021 bob saget bend a
heartfelt tribute to the comedy icon 10
days later the comedy world is mourning
the loss of sagitt himself for decades
sagitt was known for his edgy stand-up
comedy his long-running hosting stint on
america's funniest home videos and
memorable roles as danny tanner on full
house and as the narrator on how i met
your mother sagitt was actively working
as an entertainer up until the time of
his death before he unexpectedly passed
he was set to continue his nationwide
stand-up tour into the spring of 2022
now the world is in shock at the sudden
loss of the beloved performer the
unexpected death lands even harder since
it seems like saget had begun to hit his
stride on his latest comedy tour and
appeared to be gearing up for a new
phase of his career with a renewed focus
on live performance after performing
what would ultimately be his final show
sagitt tweeted
love's tonight's show pon avidra concert
hall in jacksonville appreciative
audience thanks again to tim wilkins for
opening i had no idea i did a two-hour
set tonight i'm happily addicted again
to this
condolences and remembrances have been
pouring in from fans and fellow
hollywood stars in the wake of this
tragedy a mere 10 days after saget
himself mourned the loss of another
comedy giant betty white who died a few
weeks shy of her 100th birthday i'm an
old lady to the rest of the world but to
me i'm just a girl
in the days following white's death
saget shared his memories of whites on
his instagram in the tribute the
famously blue comedian recalled a story
where he and white were on a private jet
drinking bloody marys and laughing
together he wrote i looked into her eyes
and faux romantically said how about it
betty you and me in the bathroom mile
high club she answered me before i had a
chance to finish the invite of course
bob you go in there first and i'll meet
you as soon as i finish my drink saggit
went on to jokingly add that betty
continued sipping her drink while he
waited in the bathroom for what he
claimed was over two hours assuming that
his joke might be taken totally out of
context the actor went on to clarify
that would be the joke on a joke but in
case you take things literally beyond
recollecting this humorous encounter
saget more seriously mused on white's
view of the afterlife he continued she
always said the love of her life was her
husband alan ludden who she lost in
1981. well if things work out by betty's
design they are reunited i don't know
what happens when we die but if betty
says you get to be with the love of your
life then they happily defer to betty on
this
no one could have known the world would
lose saget just a few days later and
it's especially emotional to read these
words now fans have already taken to the
instagram post comment section to
express their grief over the surprising
loss of sagi even before sagat's death
fans were showing up in droves for his
instagram post honoring betty white now
that his poignant words have a cured
additional weight in the wake of his
passing that fan response has become
even more overwhelming many commenters
picked up on white's hopeful impression
of the afterlife and ran with him
wishing saggett well in his reunion with
one of his comedy idols one commenter
with the handle young heads wrote
together now drinking bloody mary's in
heaven may you both rest in peace
another commenter that goes by tough
topic added wow you two are now angels
and we'll meet again rest in peace bob
despite coming from different
generations saggit and white clearly
touched many of the same lives and
shared many fans as a result the
comments that didn't specifically focus
on the heavenly reunion between the two
blue comics simply used the space to
honor saget a user with the handle j.i
binder wrote in the comments gonna miss
you man you brought so many smiles rest
in peace the comedy world is reading
from the loss of two titans in such
close proximity but if betty white was
right and honestly when wasn't she they
just might be cracking each other up on
another plane of existence
[Music]